ist nach zwei jahren einer schwierigen
aufbauarbeit ein sehr gutes ergebnis und
ich habe immer gesagt wir alle sind ein
gieriger haufen und ich hatte mir ein
viel schlechteres ergebnis vorgestellt
von daher
wir werden die arbeit die wir beide
gemacht haben so weitermachen kann aber
sein dass der nächste fraktionsvorstand
in der nächsten legislaturperiode auch
nur sowie stimmen bekommt ich habe damit
überhaupt kein problem
ich hätte ein problem damit gehabt wenn
irgendwer mal kurz vor 100 gelegen hätte
weil das dann irgendwie nicht ehrlich
gewesen wäre
ich habe bei götz kubitschek über die
parlamentarische arbeit gesprochen
hier im bundestag und auch mein plädoyer
gehalten warum straßenproteste diese
partei angreifbar machen beispielsweise
eine sehr strittige position und wir
unseren protest in der parlamentarischen
arbeit konstruktiv wandeln müssen bis
hin zur regierungsverantwortung das ist
das wichtigste und das ist mein ziel
gewesen bei dem mfs auch mit aufzutreten
ich halte auch das bfs für eine wichtige
vorläuferorganisation und herr
kubitschek vielleicht das noch
abschließen hat die gabe über 20 jahre
ifs auch sehr junge leute dort auch mit
zu versammeln
die mit sowie das die medien auch immer
sehr gerne schreiben mit
rechtsextremismus überhaupt gar nichts
zu tun haben ganz im gegenteil es sind
hoch gebildete junge leute die dort
hingekommen sind es hat mir sehr gut
gefallen im übrigen und da werde ich
auch persönlich weiter machen